you said
safest place now you have to realize to
a lot of people
saying bitcoin's the safest place to put
your money i mean
you're driving many people insane to say
the safest place right you know you save
an account you got
treasury bills you got gold you got a
investment company act of america with
american functions 1934 it's giving you
12.7 percent you got all these other
places
how can you save bitcoins the safest
place so
i'm going to give you two separate
frameworks that i used to think through
this right let's talk structurally first
so if i said to most people what's the
safest uh place to park your wealth
they'll say the us dollar
and that's true both in the western
world and also developing nations around
the world
there's this idea of stability safety
discipline in monetary policy like all
the things that we assign
to the us dollar and frankly things that
actually drive value in that u.s dollar
right kind of it being the global
reserve currency etc
but when you actually unpack that
structure what you find is the us
dollar's monetary policy the decisions
that drive the value of it
uh are not very transparent there's a
group of people that go in a room
privately
they make decisions we don't really have
a lot of understanding of exactly what
data they're looking at
why they're making decisions when they
make the announcements we hang on
every single word do they use dovish or
not right what
literally what color tie are they
wearing or not right it's just pretty
pretty
archaic type idea and then on top of
that we get no say
either so when they decided to do two
emergency rate cuts to the interest rate
in uh
uh q1 and q2 of 2020 all of a sudden
i had no say you had no say right then
when you look at all the quantitative
easing that's occurred
i had no say you had no say and so in
many cases
especially with the the central banking
these are not elected officials these
are appointed officials and so
again it's not something where it's the
uh kind of desires of the people now yes
they are
appointed by people that were elected so
there's kind of an indirectness to it
but i think that
when you look at it's just not a
transparent system it's a very human
driven system
when you look at bitcoin it's the exact
opposite right and the reason why that's
important is because we've moved from
this narrative-based world which is this
old legacy world
around central banking and all financial
assets to now we're in a world where
i don't believe you prove it and so
if i ask people right now how many
dollars are in circulation
there's nobody who can tell you the
exact figure right if i say to you how
many dollars were printed today
or taken out of circulation nobody can
tell you and so
that is a narrative driven world we're
told that there's something there and we
kind of directionally understand but we
don't actually have the provability
when i look at something like bitcoin
it's a fully transparent system so not
only can i tell you how many total
bitcoin there will be in the world
i can tell you exactly how many are in
circulation today i can tell you exactly
how many came into circulation
on this day exactly 900 bitcoin were
created today put into circulation
i can go back and i can actually show
you every single transaction that has
occurred since january 3rd 2009
and then on top of that and a really
important part is the monetary policy is
programmatic meaning that i can actually
tell you
the interest rate or inflation decisions
that are going to be made well into the
future literally decades into the future
because it's written in transparent code
and if that code ever changes we'll know
well in advance
and so now all of a sudden i say okay i
can choose to put my money into a fiat
currency where
i don't know the people who are making
the decision i don't know what decisions
they're going to make
and also they can do absolutely insane
things like
manipulate interest rates on emergency
schedules and
they printed 40 of all us dollars in
circulation the last 12 months
that's crazy with bitcoin bitcoin just
does what bitcoin does right we know
every day for four years is going to
produce 900 bitcoin per day put it into
circulation
and then the beauty of it is you can
look on chain at all of the data
so if you even go to something like
stocks for example again from a
structural standpoint
coinbase recently went public and when
coinbase went public i think everyone
thought the stock was just gonna take
off and
you know go to the moon well it didn't
really do that and so my initial
inclination was well maybe this is like
insiders because there's a direct
listing
uh there's no lock up here maybe there's
just insiders kind of you know capturing
their
profits and selling their cell pressure
and eventually it'll recover
but i can't go validate that in bitcoin
and crypto i can actually go look on
chain i can see
every single wallet who's selling who's
buying who's been holding how long have
they been holding
when did they get that bitcoin all that
kind of stuff and so it's just a more
transparent system
and so when i think of safety from a
structural standpoint i want to
understand as much of the system as i
possibly can then you've got to look at
okay forget my opinion forget anybody
else's opinion what's just the financial
performance
and in a year you know plus call 12-15
months
where literally there couldn't have been
more economic chaos uncertainty
bitcoin is by far the best performing
asset right if you look at the stock
markets up about 50 percent
gold is basically flat uh and bitcoin's
up 800 the last 12 months
it outperformed everything and the
reason why it did that is
because it's a supply and demand game
fixed supply
there was an awakening in the
institutional world that this
asset is going to serve as a store of
value for a long period of time
and you had a bunch of institutions
showing up trying to buy billions and
billions of dollars of bitcoin but the
bitcoiners aren't selling
sixty percent of bitcoin hasn't moved in
the last 12 months and so 60
60 has a movement in the last 12 months
this is the most important thing for
people to understand from a market
structure standpoint
so 18.6 million bitcoin are in
circulation but
60 of that has not moved in the last 12
months
and on top of that the bitcoin that is
available on the exchanges
continues to drop so actually what
you're having is more as more people are
buying it they're pulling it into cold
storage
and they're long-term holders so really
the kind of addressable circulating
supply
is only 40 of that 18.6 million bitcoin
so now when these institutions show up
with billions of dollars there's
there's not a lot of bitcoin to buy
right and that's where you get this
rapid price appreciation that we've seen
over the last 12 months
so so let me ask you this there's only a
certain supply of bitcoin i can get
right you got 18.6 million
60 no one selling 40 people are selling
so 40 of 18.6 money you do the math say
eight and a half say nine million
whatever the numbers okay
uh seven and a half million whatever the
numbers right okay
so how come if we only have a
limited amount of gold how come gold
didn't go up the same
level that bitcoin did during the same
exact period which means you can't go
print gold you can't go print uh
bitcoin why didn't gold go up the way
crypto did that bitcoin did
so i think i think there's two
components to this one is
uh the statement there's a limited
supply of gold
we don't know that again a narrative
driven world we're told that gold is
scarce
but if i ask somebody well how much gold
is there right now in the circulating
supply
again we don't know for a fact right
there's good guesses right so i don't
want to kind of
uh take the uh the uh extreme view of
like nobody knows
we have a we have an educated guess but
we don't know with 100
certainty compared to like let's say a
bitcoin the second thing
is that gold from a a social consensus
standpoint
ask anyone under the age of 35 if
they're buying gold or bitcoin
right so what you have is you have a
capital shift from older kind of the
boomer generation
down to the younger generation but the
younger generation doesn't want to hold
gold and so if you go and you look at
the same time that bitcoin went up uh
over the last like let's say six seven
months five hundred percent
gold is down pretty materially right
it's down like fifteen twenty percent
and so it's not that doesn't make any
sense mathematically
well because people are selling it right
people are dropping gold and they're
buying bitcoin now again
it is unclear how much of the people
that are dropping gold and kind of
selling gold are actually going directly
to buy bitcoin
but what you can see is you can see an
inverse relationship as
gold has gone down bitcoin has gone up
and so what i think becomes
really really interesting is again a
store of value
ends up being more of a social consensus
than a technology consensus right
and what i mean by that is bitcoin is by
far
10 100 maybe a thousand x improvement on
gold from a technology standpoint it's
more portable it's more divisible right
it's more transparent verifiable all
that kind of stuff
so from a pure just technology
standpoint it is drastically more
superior
but actually what's more important is
the social consensus
if everyone was yelling and screaming
and saying go buy gold right during this
uh kind of economic chaos
gold would have went up right but
instead what is everyone been talking
about what is cnbc talking about all day
long right what is the
uh institutional investment uh investors
all talking about bitcoin
and so naturally that's where capital
flows when capital flows to a fixed
supply asset price has to go up to
accommodate everybody
and so i think that you're just seeing a
generational shift here where
analog assets are going to get replaced
by digital assets and what history has
shown us
is that digital assets are always bigger
than their analog predecessors
because the internet is just so much
bigger than we ever give it credit for
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye